we will be talking about training large
scale models using
pyo uh I think the first question is why
should we care about training these
Large Scale Models right um so why
should we uh I'm sure bunch of you have
used chat gbt or B or or entropic claw
or or are using llama for uh doing some
stuff and all these are large scale
models and given that these models are
becoming so useful and so powerful it's
fairly useful to think about what takes
it to train these kind of large scale
models
uh the other reason to think about or
caring about training large scale moduls
is this following curve uh this is from
the neural scaling loss paper what this
shows is this is three different curves
uh on the xaxis we have compute or the
data set size or the parameters and on
the y- axis we have the test loss that
it's not important as to what the task
is that the trend that we are seeing is
as increase compute that is as we move
along the right side on the x-axis or as
we increase the size of the data set or
as we increase increase the size of the
models we see a clear Improvement in
performance indicated by the lowering of
the test loss so this is basically to
say that we care about Large Scale
Models because Large Scale Models enable
things they they have performance they
enable much better performance than
smaller scale models the other reason I
like this image a lot is because this
talks about different axis along which
you can be scaling models so one of the
axes along which you scale a model is to
train it with a lot of compute the other
axis is to train a model with a lot of
data and the third access is to train a
very big model you know a model with a
lot of parameters so very often when we
say we are training Large Scale Models
people just assume that the model is too
big but there are these two other
dimensions in terms of compute and in
terms of data set size as well and
that's going to be the theme of this
talk we'll talk about some of the common
problems that people run into when they
are trying to scale models along these
three axes and what are some of the ways
that we can get around that using
pyarge I also want to say that a bunch
of non agenda for this stock is we
wouldn't talk about how to get a lot of
training data and we wouldn't talk about
how to get a lot of compute we would
also not talk about how to do good signs
so this is in no way exhaustive talk
this is basically uh you know hey these
are the different things that you can do
for training lass skill models in P but
it's not
exhaustive okay so what are some of the
common challenges that we come across
the first challenge is that hey I have
got a lot of data available but my and
my model is not to big and when we say
my model is not too big it basically
means that the model can fit on a single
GPU uh so I've got data I've got a model
that fits on a GPU but it takes a lot of
time to finish iterating on the data set
or it takes a lot of time to train the
model on this data set so this is one of
the common challenges that we get
through and uh this is a very classic
systems problem uh this problem can be
reformulated as saying I have got a
workload that is running but it's
running too slow and I want to make it
go faster and the way to do that is to
parallelize the workload across a bunch
of machines and when we do it in machine
learning we call all this thing as data
parallel data parallel basically means
that you're consuming the data in
parallel across a bunch of machines and
in py to we specifically call it as
distributed data parallel uh where the
first distributed basically means that
you're consuming you're doing data
parallel across a bunch of machines so
you know DP or
dtp uh just to give you a sense of how
that looks like you know this is a
single GPU set if you've got a data set
you've got a model we break the data set
into batches let's say there are four
batches here and then the model starts
consuming them so at time equal to one
it consumes first batch then second
batch then third batch and fourth batch
so it takes four steps to consume the
entire data set so this is a single GPU
setup now let's say I was in a multi GPU
setup where I had multiple gpus and I
was using distributed data parallel what
would happen is that I'll still have the
same data set I'll still have the same
model and I'll still break my data set
into batches so let's say there are
still four
batches but now I would have two copies
of the model one copy running on each
GPU so if I had two gpus I'll have two
copies if I had 10 gpus I'll have have
10 copies and the benefit of having
multiple copies of the model is now I
can consume two batches at once instead
of just one batch so at time step t
equal to 1 I have consumed patch one and
Patch two and at time step two I've
consumed the remaining two batches so
instead of taking four steps to consume
the batches now I'm just taking two
steps and in that sense it makes your
training go faster uh because you're
consuming batches
faster um so that's the high level
overview of what distributed data
parallel does the the broad idea is that
you start multiple processes one process
for GPU for each process you initialize
a process group uh we wouldn't go into
details of what the process group is but
basically the idea is that these
processes need a way to communicate with
each other um if you're doing this on
CPU you can use things like NPI but if
you're doing it on gpus then you need to
use something called as nickel nickel is
kodas communication Library again we
don't have to go into those details and
the last thing is that you have to
update your data loader to use a
distributed sampler uh this bit is
needed to make sure when model one when
these two copies of model are consuming
a batch they are consuming different
batches and not consuming the exact same
batch because in that case you're not
going to see any uh
speedups uh and just to give you a quick
example of what the code could look like
for things like this uh we have a vault
size which is basically how many devices
are we using and uh we set up these DDP
processes which is basically just saying
that uh which is basically just
providing a way for these processes to
communicate so we provide a master
address and a master Port so all the
process are going to use this address
and this port to communicate and then we
just initialize the process scoup uh I
think the only interesting thing here is
this attribute called as backend equal
to Nickel nccl it's pronounced as nickel
um I think the thing to note is if you
are doing disability data parel on gpus
you should be using nickel n CCL if you
are doing disability data parallel on
CPUs you should be using blue and that's
it that's the main thing that you need
to know if you want to start using
distributed data
P okay so this is good uh just to
rearize what exactly did we do in this
challenge is we took a workload which
which was running but was running slow
and we distributed it across multiple
machines and we call this as distributed
data parallel and one other way you can
think about this problem is that you are
making the process go faster by
increasing the batch size because now
you're consuming two batches so in a
sense your batch size is doubled
now uh um one caviat to note here is
that this way of making training go
faster assumes that you have more gpus
which may not be the case all the time
but it's good to know that
caveat okay let's talk about a different
kind of challenge in this case I may
have a lot of data I may have very
little data but my model is too big my
model is so big that I cannot train even
with a bat size of one basically I
cannot do any training maybe my my my
model is just too big to even fit on a
GPU
now in a setup like this distributed
data parel is not going to help me
because what distributed data parel does
is it it allows me to increase the bat
size but for that I should be able to
load at least a batch size of one
whereas in this case I cannot even do
that so distributed data parall is out
of the way you have to think of
something else well this is another
classical systems problem uh so we have
a workload that we want to run but this
workload workload is very very large to
run and so the way we handled this
problem is we sh the workload charting
basically means we distribute or we
divide the workload across multiple
machines and in in context of machine
learning we call it as model parallelism
um I want to contrast it with data
parallelism where we had multiple copies
of the model on different devices and
the data was divided in this case the
model is going to be divided across a
bunch of machines so what we'll do is
we'll take a big model and we'll break
it down into pieces and these different
pieces would be living on different
machines this is one example of of what
model parallelism could look like so we
have got these eight blocks here uh on
the horizontal axis or in the x-axis you
have got time and these different colors
are denoting basically different
machines so you have got a model which
is distributed across four machines uh
the F0 F0 FZ FZ these four FZ basically
means that you had a batch of data which
is going through these different
machines and F basically stands for a
forward pass it basically means you're
Computing the output of the model so you
take the model you break it into four
pieces the first piece goes to the first
machine you take its output you pass it
to the second machine you take its
output you pass it to the third machine
you take its outut you pass it pass it
to the fourth machine and then the
backward starts which means you start
Computing the gradient so you compete
the gradients on the fourth machine then
you compete the gradient on the third
machine then on the second machine then
on the first machine and then the update
of the model parameters
happens uh yeah so in this way you can
break your model into as many sort of
components as you like or as many
components as you you can break it into
given the number of gpus that you have
and you can pipeline or you can sort of
create this pipeline of uh processes
happening um one obvious disadvantage of
doing something like this is there's a
lot of white space that you see here
right and this is all white space when
these machines are not really doing
anything so it Wast a lot of compute uh
when the the different machines are
sitting idle and so one other thing that
you can do is called as pipeline
parallelism which is also a different
form of model parall is M the main
difference with pipeline parallelism is
you have multiple batches in pipeline so
again let's try to interpret this plot
uh on the x-axis or in the horizontal
side you have
got uh basically time taking away uh so
you start with fz0 F0 means that on the
zeroth machine you've got the zero patch
so at time step equal to Z you get that
and time step equal to one you get a new
batch on the Zero machine but and so you
get a new batch on the Zero machine and
you take the output from the previous
patch and you pass it to the first
machine and then at time t equal to two
you take the output from the first
machine you pass it to the second
machine you take the output from the
zeroth machine you pass it to the first
machine and you you put in a new batch
into the first machine so we basically
creating a pipeline uh and the benefit
of creating a pipeline is that the
amount of wasted time or the ideal time
which is the white space in this case is
is reduced but it's effectively doing
the same kind of thing but at a better
througho and then you can do it in a in
a more fancy way to reduce the overhead
even more so in this case the uh the
white blocks with diagonal lines are the
idle States and you can see in this case
that the percentage of idle state is
actually much less so you can do all
these fancy sort of scheduling around
these things uh so py suppos start py
suppos starts with this API called as
pipeline parallelism and it's relatively
straightforward to use this API uh so
what you do is you you create a pipe and
then you take your model uh now instead
of making a standard model you make a
sequential model so that it's easy for
pipeline to break this model along
different axis uh so in this case for
example I'm making let's say I'm making
a eight layer Transformer so modu list
is going to be eight elements and I'm
saying the size of the chunks is eight
so one chunk or one module would sit on
one of the eight machines and then when
I'm doing a forward pass I do the
forward pass as before model. data and
then at the end to get the value from
the forward pass I still I have to do
this extra thing called as a loore value
which basically says give me the value
on this machine on on the specific
machine where I call the output but
other than that it it composes pretty
well with the existing construction by
touch uh
okay um now the good thing is if I have
a model which I can load finally by
dividing it across multiple machines can
I still increase the bat size with
distributed data parallel and it turns
out yes so you can do the exact same
thing uh first break your model in a
pipeline paralyser manner make it so
that it can load a decent bat size and
then you can increase that bat size by
creating copies of this pipeline model
so this is another example which is
showing this so you've got a model uh a
TS or sequential model let's say you are
putting it through a a pipeline pipe and
you're breaking into a fixed number of
chunks and then this model that comes
out you are doing distributed data
parallel over this model so uh all this
stuff around ts. parity data par this is
all boiler plate stuff and we just need
the process group again and we D this
model with DP uh so it's it's pretty
good that these two apis compose well
with each
other okay so
uh now obviously this CH fixing this
challenge also assumes that you have
enough gpus and and you can do these
things a third axis of challenges is my
layers are so big that I cannot put one
layer on a GPU so again focus on the
axis in which we we are going so we said
we have a model that fits on a GPU but
the data set is too big distributed data
parel then we said the model is too big
so we said okay let's put one layer on a
machine and then do uh training through
it and then you can combine data
parallel through it now we are talking
about a setup where even a single layer
is too big to fit on a GPU so pipeline
parallelism is not going to help us here
because I cannot pipeline parallelism as
assumes that you can put different
layers across different gpus but in this
case I cannot even do that so
distributed data parel doesn't work
model parallel doesn't work what can I
do again this is similar to the previous
classical systems problem that we have
seen we have a workflow that is very
large and the way we solve this problem
is by Shing the workload and in this
case we call this approach as tensor
parallelism and what's the difference
between tensor parallelism and model
parallelism model parallelism was
splitting a model vertically so you had
layers going across different machines
in this case you're partitioning the
model horizontally in the sense that you
could have a layer and that layer itself
a feed forward layer or a linear layer
for example is shed across different
gpus so even that layer is not on a
single
GPU an example of this is shown here so
let's see what is it that we are trying
to do let's say we are trying to compute
uh the output Y which is guu of X of a
so X is our input a is our weight Matrix
SC is a nonlinearity it's a pointwise
nonlinearity think of it as Ru for
example so I get my input X I break my
input into or I basically create two
copies of my input x and x so I have two
copies of my input my weight Matrix
capital A has been shed in two smaller
matrices A1 and A2 and these smaller
matrices are small enough that they that
they can fit on a single GPU so the
entire Matrix a was too big to fit on a
GPU but the smaller A1 and A2 can so I
first compute X of A1 on one machine I
compute X of A2 on the second machine
then I apply G I can apply G this way
because these are pointwise
nonlinearities and then I get y1 and Y2
and then I can combine these y1 and
Y2 or I could feed it through another
tensor parallel layer so let's say in
the next operation I wanted to with the
Y that I computed I wanted to compute a
y * v b is another Matrix and I wanted
to compute Dropout on top of it so in
this case I take y1 I take Y2 and then I
multiply y1 with B1 which is one of the
shs of capital B Matrix and then
multiply Y2 by the other Shard B2
compute the Z1 and z2s sort of combine
them together apply Dropout and get the
final value that I care about and again
in this case b is a full Matrix but y1
B1 and Y2 B2 could be lying on different
machines uh yeah and I also want to
highlight that you may want to for
example put x uh A1 and B1 on the same
machine so you could do that U so in
this case you're Shing the model along
the horizontal ACC does p support that
yes to a good extent uh it's somewhat of
a experimental support it's a relatively
sorry it's a relatively new thing that
was added uh but it does support that uh
through these apis like paralyze module
or paralyze parallel and so on and the
high level idea is still the same you
you define your model the usual way that
you would and then you pass it to this
paralyze module construct and it
paralyzes the layers for you but this
support is experimental uh so there are
going to be some rough edges with
this okay uh and and just like the
previous setups it assumes that you can
have more gpus and so uh yeah now the
fourth setup uh the fourth setup is more
of uh a sort of a umbrella term so I
basically want to reduce a memory
consumption of my training setup and
this challenge is sort of orthogonal to
everything else we discuss so even if I
have a lot of gpus I might still want to
reduce the memory consumption of my
trade of my training setup so so this
applies to basically all the things that
we saw so far and there are these bunch
of techniques for doing doing that uh
one of these techniques is called a CPU
offloading CPU offloading basically
means that when you're training a model
on a GPU you offload the parameters or
the gradients from GPU to CPU when
you're not using them so it it frees up
GPU memory for putting in more stuff
into that so CPU offloading is supported
in pyo uh the other thing is activation
checkpointing or as some people call it
as activation recomputation or gradient
checkpointing the high level idea is
when you do a forward pass you save a
bunch of extra information that you use
during the backward pass uh which you
don't really need for the forward pass
itself but you you use it you keep it
around so that you can use it during the
back pass so activation checkpointing
reduces that that memory consumption by
not saving these extra information doing
the forward pass and when you when you
need this information in the backward
pass you recompute it so in that sense
it's trading off memory for time it
gives you more memory but it it also
increases the time because you have to
redo these computations the Third Way
people handle and activation
checkpointing is also supported in pyto
the Third Way people can handle these is
by doing mix Precision training so
instead of using fp32 which is a 4 byte
Precision format you can use fp16 which
is a 2 by Precision format or bf16
another 2 by Precision format or tf32
which is a 19 byte format and so uh that
gives you roughly 50% memory Saving
right away uh so mix Precision training
is also supported in P Arch uh but let's
say these things were not enough and I
wanted to reduce the memory consumption
even other so then the question is who
exactly is consuming the memory and well
the model state is going to consume some
memory gradients are going to consume
memory and Optimizer is going to consume
some memory and so are the activations
all these things are things that consume
the memory so this is technique called
as fully shed data parallel where you
Shard the model State gradients and
optimizers and by sharding we mean you
have the model state but the entire
model state is not on one GPU the model
state is across a bunch of gpus and
similarly the gradients are not on one
GPU they across a bunch of of gpus and
the optimizer is also broken down in
across a bunch of gpus so fully shorted
data parallel it's a form of data
parallel and it's called fully shorted
because everything is shorted the uh the
model State the gradient optimiz
everything is shorted uh this is a high
level sort of overview of how fsdp works
but we wouldn't go into this here the
the main thing to know here is fsdp is
relatively straightforward to use with
PGE uh so you make your model uh and
then you wrap it into fstp
and after wrapping up you get a sharded
module and you use a sharded module to
create the
optimizer uh and that's it and then you
keep you know doing your standard pyot
stuff as you would do
otherwise
um yeah so I think this covers most of
the things uh that are available out of
the box for people to use for training
lar skill models with byor uh if these
things are not sufficient or if you have
a use case which doesn't which isn't
covered fully by these things PCH also
provides lowlevel apis uh called as
torch distributed torch distributed
basically provides communication
Primitives or a mechanism to for the
different gpus or different machines to
talk to each other uh so for example
when we are talking about you know this
model has been broken down across
machines and these outputs are flowing
through those machines the way you are
doing this is for example using Dodge or
distributed. send so you can say hey
gpu1 should send its activations or its
results to gpu2 or or gpu2 should pull
the results from gp1 and things like
those so those lowlevel apis are already
also exposed and you can use those to
build a different kind of solution if
the existing Solutions do not already
work for
you uh and in terms of the communication
Primitives you have Point too
communication so one GPU can talk to the
other GPU you can have Collective
operations where a group of gpus are
sort of doing some collective operations
like broadcasting or
reducing uh all these things are very
well documented on the page dos and
discuss for forums are a great place to
ask questions about
byor now we discuss a bunch of things
but there's still a lot of things that
we did not cover which is very useful
for training L Scale Models this
includes things like distributed RPC uh
it includes things like distributed
optimizers uh distributed RPC and
distributed optimizers are basically
alternative ways of Distributing your
workload distributed elastic basically
is a way where let's say you start
training a model with 100 gpus and one
of the gpus die in between in that case
your entire model training would Hal but
distributed elastic lets you continue
into training when a a subset of notes
die and this is important because when
you are training these models on let's
say a th000 gpus it is very likely that
one or more gpus could fail and if that
happens uh a small percentage of gpus
failing should not bring down your
entire training so distributed elastic
handles that for you out of the
box okay I think this is all I wanted to
talk about uh we have four more minutes
left for questions uh the slides would
be up up uploaded at this link so you
can go and and check out the slides
there and with that I'll open it up for
questions um do you also uh use a lot of
uh pie torch and uh scaling in the work
that you're doing right now yes so for
most part we use
fsdp um so far we haven't really run
into situations where we had to create
something entirely new uh so this is
good uh because creating these things is
uh debugging these things is super
annoying rating is not that hard but yes
most of our workloads run on fstp pretty
much all of it runs on
fstp
[Music]
nice I'm sure a lot of people would love
to get a
uh inside view on the stuff that you're
doing um yeah I I don't think I can talk
a lot about the exact thing that we are
trying to build
the the high level idea is we are trying
to train a bunch of um multimodel
Foundation models multimodel in the
sense that you have got multiple
modalities uh that people can interact
with that people can
use uh
and they should be able to use these
things at the same time uh instead of so
one view is that you can train these
independent models and just sort of fuse
them together and this is called as late
Fusion late Fusion basically means you
have these independent models and then
you're combining their output early
Fusion means that uh you are training it
in a multimodal way right from the start
uh so yeah we we are focusing somewhat
more on that kind of a uh setup but I
don't think I can talk too much about
the end use case that we are hoping to
make
cool um yeah uh thank you again for uh
you know talking about uh all the
different
considerations and uh you know ways to
deal with large scale uh Mach learning
um great thank you for having me and for
organizing this conference it's exciting